people tried to you know declare me as
an antiva now I want to jump to an
interview over the weekend with tennis
champion novic jokovic who is now the
most acclaimed tennis player of all time
you may remember he couldn't get to a
couple Grand Slams during covid because
he would not get vaxxed and uh I think
he's turned out to be quite right about
all that and uh listen to him about
Freedom correct me if I'm wrong you were
not against vaccination you just did not
want it for yourself exactly people try
to you know declare me as an antiva I'm
not antiva no I'm Pro proex I'm I'm I'm
Pro freedom to choose yeah this is a guy
who now has more tennis Awards major
Grand Slam wins than anybody he skipped
the US uh open he was not allowed in the
United States because he didn't get the
VAC so he could have even more accolades
than he has but he he's a tennis player
right like I don't think this is someone
that 15 years ago would have been like
I'm I will be on the Forefront of
fighting for freedom and medical
autonomy right he was like I like to
play tennis but we find people out of
all walks of life that then become sort
of avatars for the way we should all be
living